الطائرات القصيره الانتحاريه عادت لتحلق
في اجواء اوكرانيا هذه المره فوق مدينه
اوديسا مسؤولون اوكرانيون اشار الى ان
الكهرباء انقطعت عن جميع مرافق البنيه
التحتيه غير الحيويه في المدينه الساحليه
جنوب اوكرانيا بعد اطلاق روسيا طائرات
مسيره لقصف منشات الطاقه الرئيس الاوكراني
قال ان غارات روسيه بطائرات مسيره تركت
مليون ونصف المليون نسمه بلا كهرباء في
منطقه اديسون زلينسكي ايضا الى ان 10
طائرات مسيره ايرانيه الصنع تم اسقاطها
اثناء الغاره الروسيه بينما وصلت خمس
طائرات اخرى لهدفها ما الحق اضرار جسيمه
بالبنيه التحتيه الطاقه وفي الاثناء حذرت
مصلحته الكهرباء المحليه في اوديسا من ان
تصليح الاعطال قد يستغرق اسابيع وربما
يصلوا لثلاثه
بدوره قال حاكم اديس مكسيم ماشينكو ان
البنيه التحتيه الضروريه فقط والمتعلقه
بالمستشفيات تم تزويدها بالكهرباء مشيرا
الى ان الوضع لا يزال صعبا لكنه تحت
السيطره نذكر اخيرا بان الرئيس الروسيب
لديمير بوتن تعهد يوم الخميس
بالاستمرار في ضرب شبكه الطاقه الاوكرانيه
رغم صيحات الاستنكار الدوليه ضد الهجمات
التي تركت ملايين الاشخاص فريسه للبرد
والظلام
[موسيقى]